VR Queen and Forte Tapas owner Nina
mancham is here to tell us about her
forte and Friends Chef residency Series
where she lets guest chefs take over her
restaurant with their Concepts and menus
and joining us to tell us more is Nina
and current guest Chef Joshua Bianchi
welcome you two thank you now Josh is
starting his meal and I can't wait to
talk to you about this but Nina you've
got to tell us what a great idea idea
tell us a little about Forte and Friends
Forte and friends was inspired by uh
wanting to bring something new to the
community and wanting to showcase the
talent and you know inspiration from
these different chefs who don't have
their own restaurant but actually want
to create their own restaurant and
giving them the space to connect with
the customers and try different things
out in like a fun casual kind of sort of
setting so what a cool idea and what a
great thing to do for the chefs and Chef
Josh I've had your cooking before I
can't imagine tell us about your menu
and what you're going to be showcasing
so right now I'm making porcini anilotes
with a white truffle butter the menu is
um it's like Italian American Center
French Bistro Flair
seasonal I try to change up the
ingredients every couple of weeks or so
new dishes and things like that I
brought some bread today that's I always
showcase the bread every weekend on
Sundays and Mondays the bread is great
but I want to see what you're making
here and you said you can put this
together really quickly yeah just about
ready to see okay he's making the pasta
now Nina tell us a little bit more about
uh about your restaurant and where it's
located and how many days a week are we
going to be doing this so Chef Josh is
there on Sundays and Mondays uh we're
open all week throughout as well and we
just started doing lunch and our Cuisine
is mostly highlighting Eastern European
Cuisine I'm Bulgarian so it's a lot of
family recipes and things like that but
we go mainly on like home cooking fresh
ingredients making everything from
scratch kind of inviting people into our
homes and that's what Josh has been
doing too I mean he makes everything
fresh every single day
it takes him like what two three days to
make this bread from start to finish and
it's freaking phenomenal and like
different sharing plates and stuff
because we do a lot of Tapas so you know
you build kind of your community and
sharing I love that okay Josh are we how
are we doing this about there okay I
just want to tighten up the sauce right
now with some Parmesan you got this
smells amazing I smell Truffle in this
too that's it the Truffle is making it
for me and if people want to come where
are you located we're located on the
Southeast corner of rainbow Flamingo
4180 South Rainbow and we're in the
lavonita and Lee's Liquor Shopping
Center OH wonderful now do they have to
make special reservations to come and
check out Josh's menu I mean it's all
reservations are always recommended just
to make sure you have a seat but pop in
say hi chef Josh comes out and talks
with the people and everything so you
get to meet this amazing Chef hear about
his inspiration and try his amazing food
so the caviar Queen and Chef Josh in one
spot I I can't imagine that it gets any
better than that he is wrapping up here
we are gonna watch you played that and
just suggest that everyone go check it
out if you want more information
definitely visit their website it's bar
forte.com and you can experience this
amazing food thank you Chef thank you so